trois jours après les inondations qui
ont touché la commune de oui le ministre
de l'intérieur gerra darmanin s'est
rendu sur place
il a échangé avec les forces de secours
mobilisés ce jour là on a répondu
présent
on a fait de sauvetage on a aidé les
gens à on a fait au mieux on a pu et on
a répondu à l'appel des habitants de riz
toute la commune a été touchée par les
inondations
la mairie des commerçants et des
riverains demandent maintenant la
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
mardi donc la réunion de la commission
ce fait il ya plusieurs ministères
autour de la table évidemment le
ministère de l'intérieur
mais d'autres ministères concernés comme
celui de la transition et écologique
sain bref l'agriculture bien sûr et sur
des dossiers sur des critères qui sont
bien établis nous décrétons par un
décret que je proposerai au premier
ministre président de la république
l'état de catastrophe naturelle
j'ai toute confiance que la commune de
beauvais les communes du sud de l'aisne
la commune douillet d'autres communes
des yvelines d'ailleurs seront retenus
le ministre a également rencontré
certains habitants du quartier tonkin
l'un des plus touchés les riverains ont
fait part de leur désarroi et de leurs
besoins
gérald darmanin était accompagné de la
députée du territoire je pense que
c'était important que le ministre vient
de voir l'étendue des dégâts viennent
saluer aussi les forces qui étaient
intervenus parce qu'elles ont fait à peu
près 500 interventions il ya une dame
dont la vie a pu être sauvé la
protection civile a beaucoup aidés aussi
au pompage des maisons et puis malgré
tout crois que les habitants ont été
très traumatisés par cet événement et
c'est toujours bien que le politique
viennent à leur rencontre pour les
écouter et pour aussi prendre conscience
que c'est pas seulement du matériel
c'est aussi beaucoup d'émotion la mairie
et la communauté d'agglomération vont
maintenant réfléchir conjointement à des
aménagements possibles pour éviter
d'autres inondations